hello my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara just saw and Cody also
just saw two as well absolutely I just
saw the Lego franchises third movie
Ninjago now in true Tamara fashion I
haven't actually seen the original lego
movie I saw a Lego Batman and I was very
pumped to see this one again why do I
wait to see things like I know I am
going to enjoy the crap out of the lego
movie ah such a lazy movie watching this
was a lot of fun though I have been
seeing as everyone else has because Lego
is a giant franchise who knows how to
market themselves I've been seeing a ton
of previews and trailers for this film
and they're all edited really well
they're hilarious and the hype was real
I was very excited to see this movie
especially coming after Lego Batman
which was super funny super still a
Batman film but just with that silly
Flair Lego has got their own weirdly
this is so weird to say because it's a
toy franchise it's like build-a-bear
connect the Lincoln Logs plastic toys
Lego that should be their slogan
build-a-bear connect the plastic Lincoln
Log toys Lego copyright that's mine now
but like I was saying before that
lightning bolt of inspiration came to me
Lego had this weird sense of comedy that
is unique to their movies in a way that
when I saw the first trailers for the
lego movie I thought why are why why oh
why oh why why why why do we need a lego
movie and that's coming from someone who
enjoys like the lego video games and
grew up with the lego racers and lego
indiana jones and you know so I don't
know why I was so skeptical towards it
maybe because it's a toy company making
a movie so odd to me still so so weird
because other franchises other big
brands have tried to make movies I don't
know
actually seems like they more just kind
of threw stuff on the wall and whatever
didn't stick they used this film was
again really funny uniquely so it has
great humor while keeping itself really
clean can still have a lot of fun geared
towards like parents and adults and it's
just a delight it's just a delight to
sit through I was watching the previews
before the film started and like three
of them had a fart joke or like a potty
humor like a poop joke or something it's
like oh kid movies poop jokes and the
lego movie this Ninjago movie had none
of that so that's cool like the writing
is superior for for it being geared
towards younger audiences it's it's a
good film which is what younger audience
geared towards films should aimed for
kind of said that in a better sentence
the movie started out and I know Batman
so seeing Lego Batman was it was funny
in its own sense because it was Batman
in silly situations which is a lot of
fun this I didn't know the Ninjago story
so I think it was a little less invested
up front and I even wrote down I was
like ah it's a little less fun but still
so solid still so good but by the end I
was just did not mean that at all that
go away phone notes you are not welcome
here i GD cried you guys I cried I cried
AF I cried it a lego movie good god it's
so sweet and earnest and their little
plastic they don't even have fingers
they don't even have fingers something
that the Batman one did as well I'm not
sure if the first one did but I imagine
it did is they cut to real-life things
as well so in the beginning and the very
end it's kind of book ended by a cute
endearing scene with real people real
actors there's a real cat and it's not
real it's it's CGI but it's made to look
real in the Lego universe those are
really fun and the Batman ones they did
all the comebacks to be older Batman
move
he's Batman so those are really fun
moments and it kind of for some reason
to me just shows that they're not taking
it too seriously in a good way where
you're like oh everyone having fun this
is fun let's have fun we have fun here a
really great moment is when the team of
ninjas who are gonna fight the bad guy
they get their elements and then the
ninja warrior tells them what their
ultimate power is and each of them is
specific and you find out that one of
them is is really lame and it's such a
fun moment I love that it's just very
Captain Planet Eve earth fire wind water
I electrocute thinks dude no you don't
I'm ice that's just sad I'm Hart there's
some really fun moments in the film I
mean throughout the whole film but to me
it's just wonderful how they pace it
like there's there's a couple of serious
moments and then the ninja master starts
playing it's a hard-knock life with his
ninja cane and it's like well yep that's
exactly what I'm talking about with the
lego movie sense of humor they have such
good moments of seriousness in the lego
movies no they make fun of the
stereotypes in some ninja movies where
there's just like the training montage
then they're super all of a sudden
really good and that kind of time lapse
issue in a lot of ninja movies they also
make fun of like a stereotype with a
they call the female ninjas girl ninja
that's really funny to me so Jackie Chan
is in this film he's the the master Lego
master and there's also just some really
obscure actors not obscure I guess but
people that I I heard I'm like I know
you I know who you are but not
immediately recognizable Fred Armisen
and dave franco the voice acting was
great just like the last one another
thing that is just so interesting about
this is all of the merchandise that they
can now sell because it started off as
toys and then they made a movie and then
they're gonna make all the toys from the
movie
it's brilliant it is a brilliant
brilliant way to make money and it's not
just a blatant slap in your face like
the emoji movie where it's like oh this
is the brand the brand the brand pomf
pomf pomf it's like it's actually good
and well done and enjoyable and I mean
they're not gonna stop making these
soaps cuz they're so good the writing is
excellent the voice acting is excellent
the animation is beautiful and for some
reason it doesn't annoy me to be
watching this film and see the lego
brand on everything why doesn't that
annoy me because it's a good product I
think I don't know maybe they're just
brainwashing us all oh wow it's got a 47
percent on Rotten Tomatoes six point
seven out of ten on imbd I am DB and
ninety-one percent liked this movie
though so I mean that's I guess pretty
telling
critics versus actual like the people
watching cuz reviewers aren't actual
people you know what I mean I think it
was a little slow up top but I'm getting
into it the end was not difficult listen
I'm gonna be up for something always
when the main villain is a cat do you
know me at all yes I'm gonna love this
film
so I would recommend this movie if you
like to the Batman Ninja Batman ninja
movie if you liked the Batman Lego movie
I really think that this is slightly
less fun but but still just just a good
time it's fun just see it I should take
my own advice maybe see the original one
I didn't see Kingsman two this week
because I also haven't seen Kingsman one
so I'm gonna try to remedy that this
week and then see Kingsman next week for
Tamra just saw again follow me on
Twitter and let me know if you have any
suggestions or constructive criticism
for this series I'm always looking to
make things a bit better and trying to
desperately become a better these are
always my videos are always just my
reaction to a film I'm definitely not a
film reviewer film critic in any
sense of the word I've not seen any
films so oh good I mean I appreciate
everyone watching so if you have any
constructive criticism or ideas for the
show like if you think I should do the
whole show while doing a headstand or I
could do the whole show while eating
marshmallows you know things that will
help things that'll really improve the
quality of Tamra just let me know I'm at
Tamra L chambers on Twitter and I will
see you all next week with either
Kingsman or some other just delight just
just delight oh my god it is me Ellis
here to attack the set of Tamara's never
seen in Tamara just saw always dangerous
and I'm quaking with fear oh he smells
like such a good kitty oh it's so scary
there he goes to take a nap a
destructive nap Oh bye buddy
[Music]